the government's furlough scheme has
been extended for an
extra month until the end of april it
had been due to expire
at the end of march the chancellor rishi
sunak has also announced the extension
of government loan schemes until the end
of march to support
businesses let's bring in skies
economics editor ed
conway why has the chancellor announced
this and done this now ed
well it is a bit of a surprise move we
weren't expecting anything on this
essentially
it means that the follow scheme goes on
for an extra month and then various of
those other business schemes are
extended as well so the photo scheme was
going to end
at the end of march now it's going to
end at the end of april but actually it
goes beyond that in terms of the the
detail of what we're hearing about
from the treasury and the first uh
crucial thing is that
it's not just an extension of the
federal government remember what we're
talking about here is that the
government
is providing 80 percent uh of wages of
those who can't necessarily work as a
result
of covert 19. now there was going to be
a review of that and a lot of people
thought that at that point
charles i said it was going to come in
the new year that the treasury might
scale that back so the government was
paying
less of those wages that needed to be
supported well
what's essentially happened today is
he's brought that forward and he's made
that decision
and it is going to continue he's not
going to scale it back it is going to
continue at 80
all the way through until the end of
april so that's quite significant
actually even more so in a way
than the extension it doesn't have that
hanging over if you're an employer or an
employee
under the scheme you know that there is
going to be that support going through
uh to april i think the other thing
that's significant is that we've learned
that the date of the budget is going to
be march
the third and why are those two dates
significant the end of april for the
fellows game the start of march
for the budget it potentially means that
the chancellor can it start to introduce
measures in that march budget
that try to get the economy going again
in time for the photo scheme to come to
an end so people don't start to lay off
their workers uh before uh will they
learn basically what kind of support
there's gonna be whether it's gonna be
tax cuts or spending
increases but i think finally when you
kind of take an overarching sense of
what we're learning about
uh from the treasury it is the sense
that many of these restrictions
that we've been hearing about today are
likely to continue well into the new
year
and as a result of that the government
thinks that more economic support is
going to be necessary not just
for the first few weeks and months of
next year but potentially all the way
into the middle of the spring
towards the end of april underlining
just how concerned they are
that there will continue to be
disruption to the economy as a result
of covert 19. so i think a lot to dig
into it in terms of the subtext
but the substantial news is an extension
of the furlough scheme
and that idea that the 80 was going to
be reduced well that's
off the table for the time being